[Musica]
sono un uomo di campo un uomo che è nato
dal campo vivendo con i contadini
vivendo con gli operai quindi di
famiglia in un'azienda agricola
forse avrei voluto sempre occuparmi di
cooperazione meno è stato dato quindi
l'opportunità quindi di farlo però quest
uomo di campo e poi passato quindi su
altri campi cambi presenti quindi in
altri paesi e quindi anche quindi lo
scenario quindi del operare quindi
insieme del vivere insieme del costruire
insieme
anziché essere su una scala quale quella
comunque quindi di un'azienda è
diventata una scala su valenza quasi
quindi regionale è cambiata la scala
geografica perché adesso quindi ci sono
persone con cui si collaborano che sono
gli agricoltori forse anche quindi
pescatori ma anche comunque degli
esperti anche di funzionari quindi dei
direttori quindi dei ministri è questo
quindi l'ambiente con cui quindici opere
è questa la cooperazione e questo è co
operare insieme quindi con loro bene la
cooperazione mi ha risucchiato e questo
quindi da vent'anni rappresenta un po la
quotidianità cooperazione abitudine il
futuro perché perché se noi pensassimo
un domani diverso con quindi degli
interventi che fossero sostenibili come
quindi si diceva ho anche sani
probabilmente la cooperazione non
avrebbe avuto o non ha più senso o non
avrebbe quindi più senso da questo punto
di vista forse è bene fare una
carrellata di ciò che è stato fatto ciò
che si sta facendo con poco quasi con
niente ma solo con la volontà di operare
solo quindi con la passione solo quindi
tra virgolette con l'amore del verso
quindi lavoro e verso quindi quello che
può essere quindi un condividere con gli
altri
un primo esempio che piace quindi
ricordare e per esempio quindi l'egitto
parliamo quindi del governo rato quindi
di aswan circa 1.400 chilometri più a
sud quindi del cairo
un governo dato che le persone reddito
comunque quindi del singolo quindi
cittadino e o circa quindi di 50 dollari
al mese
queste persone hanno la necessità di
avere degli animali da cortile hanno la
necessità quindi di potersi auto
approvvigionare ma c'è un piccolo quindi
problema che forse sfugge quello della
superstizione il malocchio
quindi proprio per far fronte a questo
le galline le anatre vengono allevate in
gabbie coperte perché il vicino non le
possa guardare e non li possa tra
virgolette tirare quindi piedi e questo
comunque quindi l'aspetto che con cui
quindi si prende in considerazione un
animale che vive senza la possibilità
quindi il sole senza la reazione
questo significa vivere non in
condizioni di benessere e questa stessa
situazione si traduce verso la famiglia
che deve nutrirsi di questi animali di
queste bestie
purtroppo cresciute in condizioni di
cattività è comunque igieniche estreme
il lavoro della cooperazione cosa è
stato far comprendere come un eventuale
presenza quindi di animali che abbiano
la fortuna quindi di potersi anche
quindi esporre quindi al sole potessero
quindi essere con una resa migliore
quindi con una crescita migliore quindi
più sana e quindi farla anche qui di
apprezzare a colui che ne avrebbe poi
dopo trasformato quindi in un piatto
questa quindi la nostra nostra
cooperazione con zero ma solo con la
possibilità di poter entrare all'interno
quindi di un sistema di fiducia e quindi
di relazione
ma se poi volessimo dire che qualcosa si
può fare anche con delle tecnologie
possiamo eventualmente spostarci su su
un altro contesto quale quello della
della tunisia sud della tunisia confine
quindi con la libia bene qui come già
dall'immagine vedete delle donne delle
donne che trascorrono ore
piegate scalze o comunque quindi con
scarpe non usano gli stivali e
tendenzialmente e durante e quindi
l'inverno e non durante l'estate perché
durante l'inverno le basse temperature
permettono di avere o meno tossine e
quindi di poter lavorare quindi meglio
tutte queste cose quindi bisogna poi
vedere cioè voi non vogliamo avere le
tossine però vogliamo avere forse queste
donne vivono in condizioni di disagio
la donna cosa fa abbassata a tante ore
scruta quella profondità quindi
dell'acqua da cui spera quindi di vedere
una bolla d'aria che tradisce la
presenza di una vongola sul fondo
bene dei raccoglie questa bombola e ne
raccoglie per circa due chili non più di
tre chili al giorno
questo e vongole sono quelle veraci che
noi consumiamo nelle nostre linguine con
le vongole con i nostri quindi spaghetti
pongono e che vengono pagate sul posto a
queste donne circa un euro forse quindi
2 ma poi vendute per ben 10 15 volte
quindi di più all'interno quindi dei
nostri paesi delle nostre nostre
situazioni bene qui cos'era la
tecnologia la tecnologia fornire delle
semplici attrezzature perché loro
pensassero di purificare queste queste
vongole anche in periodi che non fossero
quelli invernali ma quelli della
primavera dell'estate quando invece ci
sarebbe stato quindi un problema legato
a condizioni quindi geni che questo
permette quindi alla donna anche di
poter i confezionarle e di poterle
vendere quindi lasciare col guadagnano
più a terzi ma prenderlo acquisirlo ed
enit a tornare quindi a casa con la
possibilità di poter anche dire che io
conto
la donna non conta più solo quindi per
quel lavoro che faceva in casa che torna
a casa ma conta anche per una comunità
per una dignità quindi che acquisisce è
che nel rispetto quindi di un ambito
motto quindi più ampio
certamente quindi si traduce si traduce
in una condizione quindi di sviluppo non
solo economico ma anche quindi sociale
un innesco di un qualcosa che certamente
porta quell'effetto quell'effetto onde
se invece volessimo eventualmente
portare qui sono soltanto esempi senza
nulla senza le grandi investimenti
cooperazione è quello scegliere e
individuare cosa poter fare da nulla un
altro esempio possiamo andare per
esempio quindi della siria c'è comunque
chi non ha mai sentito parlare di silvia
in questi ultimi otto anni
e qui e prima c'è stato dato quindi un
esempio di perché ci troviamo la ma
hanno in questo caso la volontà di
questa comunità e di poter restare nelle
proprie aree di non migrare e quindi la
cooperazione che cosa si è tradotta si è
tradotta nel chiedere alle persone ma
cosa eventualmente voi vorreste noi
vogliamo stare qui
ma come stare qui quindi interpetrare
questa loro quindi volontà che si è
tradotta poi nel per capire che ciascuna
quindi di loro
queste donne poi diremo perché avevano
quindi delle produzioni di latte non
usate per il consumo quindi familiare
cioè degli avanzi della giornata l'idea
con loro è stata ma tu lo mettereste
insieme con altri avanzi quindi di latte
delle altre famiglie si cosa mi offre in
cambio ti offre in cambio che tu potrai
produrre dello yogurt potrebbe produrre
del formaggio potrai di collocare questo
tuo prodotto sul mercato nei giorni
successivi e quindi averne quindi un
valore questo e va a raccogliere il
niente la piccola produzione che diventa
invece un prodotto ad altissimo
adattissimo quindi valore anche in
questo caso la tecnologia è stata
semplice è stata quella di far arrivare
comunque un pastorizzatore ma anche di
far sentire loro vicine qualcuno che
potesse eventualmente intervenire come
una sorta quindi di telefono azzurro
qualcuno che lo alza e sa che dall'altro
capo c'è qualcuna bene questo e bari
bari è un punto di riferimento perché
risponde ad esigenze di wind e dei
problemi
queste donne chi sono
sono vedove sono donne lasciate sole
ci sono donne i cui mariti comunque
hanno migrato sono ragazze sono comunque
anche donne con disabilità che si sono
incontrate sono donne di diverse
confezioni insieme sono donne che hanno
deciso che quella tecnologia non resta
solo esclusivamente al loro servizio è
una tecnologia che potesse essere usata
con partecipata con altri e quindi qui
ancora una volta senza soldi far tornare
nel senso che una settimana è un gruppo
di famiglie che utilizza questa
tecnologia
questa tecnologia è lasciata
all'utilizzo alla settimana successiva
ad altre ad altre donne
questa è la collettività quindi del
lavoro questo è il senso di comunità
questo è il senso dello vivere insieme
del potere quindi condividere delle
opportunità per il futuro
leggendo quello quindi che è necessario
bene allora cooperare jones lottando
quindi tre esempi ma ci abbiamo detto
che cooperare
quindi se effettivamente noi dradi
cassino tutta una serie quindi di
comportamenti di cattive abitudini bene
allora non ci sarebbe più bisogno dei
cooperanti
no invece il cooperante c'è sempre
bisogno c'è la necessità di dover
guardare con degli occhi innovanti cioè
farsi quindi che siano altri a guardare
cooperazione fa rima con innovazione
mettere insieme se noi dovessimo pensare
di raggiungere un obiettivo quindi un
fine ma a fare quindi questo senza aver
ascoltato quindi è sentito l'altro il
nostro fine non si sarebbe mai potuto
tradurre in un qualcosa quindi di valido
ed insostenibile e quindi è questo però
guardiamolo con occhi diversi
guardiamolo nel tempo e in questo modo
continueremo ad avere quindi un lavoro
come per esempio il la storia quindi del
granchio blu che certamente avrete
sentito quindi dal anche dalle nostre
parti quindi arrivate questo granché una
calamità è un granchio che viene con le
acque di zavorra dei grandi container
che attraversa nel canale di suez è un
granchio che viene comunque da
sistemiche ed ambienti caldi le acque
zone vengono riversate poi il mare
quando vengono scaricate nel golfo
quindi di gaber e il granchio s'è
insediato sta distruggendo grandi parte
quindi di riproduzione quindi di
crostacei ma anche attacca le reti dove
quindi il pescatore suppone quindi di
poter trovare il suo pesce invece quindi
trova un granchio che avendo gli acholi
uncinati non riesce più a staccarsi e
quindi dalla rete le reti che sono
sempre di più il materiale comunque
diciamo quindi in plastica non possono
che essere tagliate per far sì che il
granchio si è staccato e questo
significa dover ripartire un problema e
quindi la necessità di ritornare a dei
sistemi che siano anche quindi degli
attrezzi quindi più semplici
ecco la storia del granchio blu e anche
questo senza nulla fare senza nulla a
dare ma dare solo un semplice
suggerimento ma perché non pensiamo
quindi di recuperare la polpa di questi
granchi e ed eventualmente farla
inscatolare bene è questo che è
diventato la filiera del granchio blu la
filiera di una calamità che diventa una
opportunità si è creata una associazione
di pescatori del grand bleu
a zarzis aria da dove avete sentito
tante volte barconi partono per delle
destinazioni forse quindi di speranza e
di vita
quindi per chiudere
ritorniamo quindi a dire dobbiamo saper
dialogare
dobbiamo sapere quindi ascoltare
dobbiamo quindi pensare anche quindi a a
costruire insieme quindi con gli altri
e qui potrei prendere anche in prestito
quindi una una frase quindi del dalai
lama
quindi se noi in effetti dessimo i mezzi
i problemi si risolverebbero quindi da
soli
e questo quello che noi quindi vogliamo
dare quello che è necessario per non
cambiare la loro dignità ma a crescerla
noi non vogliamo portare quindi delle
soluzioni se queste soluzioni non sono
costruite con loro quello quindi che
crediamo e che è necessario ed è quello
che il messaggio
parte quindi da bari con quindi le
diverse cooperazioni internazionali
compresi l'italia è creare un ambiente
di sviluppo ma che sia quello quindi
sostenibile è di una crescita quindi
comune per tutti grazie
[Musica]